we're going in three two one
[Music]
let's go get this son of a [ __ ] hi
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my non-spoilery Avengers and game review
I had a chance to see the movie at the
premiere last night so always explain as
much as I can without getting into
spoilers and whether or not they
actually stuck the landing because that
seems almost like an impossible task at
this point after everything that they've
done so far but big tip bring a bag
lunch in a diaper because it is over
three hours long and there is no
intermission it's not so much a movie as
it is a big cultural event there's not
gonna be something this big for a long
long time so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's gonna be a
whole bunch of Avengers stuff happening
in the next couple of weeks we'll be
talking about this movie all the way to
spider-man far from home this summer in
July we'll do a new round of the IMAX
take a giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the Avengers on the video
and please do not post spoilers in this
video I will be doing all those Easter
eggs full review all that stuff later
this week when the movie comes out we
can talk about all the spoilers during
those but whatever you have in mind when
you're thinking about Avengers end game
this will blow your expectations out of
the water
think about what the best version of a
Marvel movie could be this does that and
goes beyond now I know there's a lot of
people that might not be huge Marvel
fans out there the film does work as its
own film even if you haven't seen
previous Marvel films but I would
recommend that you watch at least a
couple other Marvel films before you go
see this because the film does spend so
much time with each of the characters
you understand a little bit about why it
has to be over three hours long because
you're almost getting like small mini
sequel movies for each of the characters
during it one of the previous complaints
against the earlier Marvel films that
they're really heavy on spectacle really
light on character work because there's
just so much that you have to do during
a big Avengers film this film gives you
like an extra hour worth of material
just so that you can spend that time
with each of those characters closing
down each of their arcs or at least the
first 22 films worth of their arcs
you probably heard Kevin Feige other
people talking about this like it's the
last big Avengers film really what that
means is is that the last Avengers film
that's focused on the infinity saga the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos the Infinity
stones with these six original Avengers
so like Marvel has a couple things
behind the scenes that it had to use
event
in Game four like they want to bring in
all these new characters tell new
different kinds of stories tell stories
in different ways that you haven't seen
them do before that's gonna be Marvel
phase four so every ten years or so I
wouldn't be surprised if they sort of
shatter their universe secret war style
or something like that so that they can
completely change up the way they do
things without getting into spoilers
don't think of the movie as an ending
think of it as a new beginning for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because this
is comic books so every possible comic
book twist you could imagine like I said
whatever your expectations are for
endgame it blows those out of the water
they do this really amazing thing where
they find ways of reference saying all
the really biggest moments from previous
Marvel films and then adding context to
those so it makes the older film seem
even cooler after watching endgame so
it's not just the next step in this big
long story they've been telling this
whole time it also makes you think about
all the Marvel films in a little
different way so it's very rewarding to
longtime MCU fans if you're big Marvel
fan you've been falling all the film's
you're a big fan of Easter eggs this
film is gonna keep you busy for a long
time like you'll probably have to go see
it a couple times just to catch
everything I'll probably have to go see
it a couple times this weekend to catch
all the Easter eggs but just to talk
about the characters a little bit far
away MVP of the movie is Captain America
yes the film spends a lot of time with
each member of the original six because
the movie really is about their
storyline I really feel like whereas
infinity war was Iron Man leading the
charge and you just had really big
moments with the other Avengers endgame
is Captain America's turn but it's not
meant to be the polar opposite of that
it's not like they completely flipped
all the storylines they tell the story
in a very different way than they did
during Avengers infinity war so it's not
like they shove Iron Man in the closet
the whole time because Captain America
barely spoke during infinity war and he
only had a couple really big scenes
including the big battle of Wakanda so
within the first 15 minutes of the film
you'll understand exactly why they did
not call end game infinity War part 2
because the story itself the plot in the
way they tell the story structurally
just the way they made the film is so
different from the way they did Avengers
infinity war they do an amazing job of
providing a bookend for Captain
America's time in the MCU and his total
story since his first film they also do
a good job of resolving the Captain
America Iron Man relationship remember
an infinity war Bruce Banner just has no
idea what's going on between them
I fell out hard we're not on speaking
terms what do you mean you're not
talking to him they sort of established
the Captain America Iron Man
relationship in the MCU in the first
Avengers um so there's a lot of great
payoffs for their relationship during
endgame Iron Man himself is the backbone
of the MCU in real life and within the
movie universe - Robert Downey jr. in
the original Iron Man movie are the
reason why Marvel Studios exists the way
that they do today if that movie hadn't
been successful there would be no Marvel
Studios so in a weird way all 22 films
have found ways of either invoking him
referencing him or being about him even
if Robert Downey jr. wasn't in the movie
Robert Downey jr. is on fire during the
film he brings his a game literally and
figuratively because this is an Avengers
film Avengers Assemble Hulk was amazing
during the movie if you're one of those
people that's really bummed out that
Universal has been such a stickler and
Marvel's had trouble doing a solo Hulk
film end game really does give you that
amazing Hulk film Kevin Feige even said
before thor ragnarok that because they
weren't gonna be doing a hulk solo film
they would give him a three movie long
arc that would feel like a whole solo
film just broken into three pieces
avengers endgame is the third part of
that big story so like I said the real
reason why the movie is over three hours
long is because they spend that time
doing character work with each of the
original Avengers characters they do not
do Hawkeye dirty again I know after they
left him out infinity war everybody got
really pissed and it made it seem like
the character just wasn't a big priority
for their big plan but Hawkeye was a
badass
during Avengers end game and I'm even
more excited about this suppose that
Hawkeye Disney Plus series that they've
been talking about I will do more Marvel
phase 4 videos for the plans that they
have for each of these characters next
week probably after everyone has had a
chance to see the movie because Kevin
Bucky has announced plans for most of
the original six Avengers with a few
exceptions and a lot of those plans will
surprise you so they're weird overall
plan for Marvel phase four will make a
lot more sense after you see Avengers
endgame I love what the Russos did with
the Black Widow character ever since
they started working with her in Captain
America winter soldiers he's been so
much more interesting to me she was
never one of my favorite comic book
characters I never spent a lot of time
reading her titles but I've loved
Scarlett Johansson's take ever since she
started working with the Russos and
Winter Soldier they even do a great job
of bookend
her relationship with Hulk that they
established during Avengers age of
Ultron they just released a promo where
she's like I never used to have anything
and this Avengers team gave me a family
so you really get inside her head in a
way that you have not before it really
wasn't until Avengers age of Ultron that
you started to get a sense for what she
was thinking what was going on up in her
head so when game does a good job of
continuing that threat well also at the
same time allowing her to be super
badass of course all the Avengers and
all the characters are badass during the
film speaking of which we got to talk
about Thor I've done a lot of Thor
videos recently but he just came alive
during Thor Ragnarok so if you like that
newer energy that he brought to the
character they totally continue that and
more during Avengers endgame so yes Thor
is one of the most powerful characters
of the MCU he gets to do so much crazy
stuff that will blow your expectations
away but there's also a lot of really
big surprises from the character during
the movie - you will experience the most
extreme versions of every possible human
emotion during the film you will laugh
harder than you have ever left you
probably cry a lot you'll probably cheer
harder than you've ever cheered
hopefully you won't wait your pants
hopefully you'll find a good time to go
to the bathroom but fair warning there
is no good time to go to the bathroom
because every moment during this film is
so crazy they totally stuck the landing
there were a lot of big surprises I
wasn't expecting I had a lot of theories
and ideas about what I wanted from these
characters they gave me a little bit of
what I wanted and a lot of stuff that I
didn't know that I needed so there were
a couple really big surprises for me
during the movie most of the footage
that they've released of the film
officially is from the first little bit
so you have no idea what's happening
during this film even if you feel like
trailers give away a lot of the plot of
the film you have no idea the visual
effects were next level obviously the
spectacle was off the charts there isn't
gonna be a film this big for a long time
and I'm also talking about Star Wars
later this year there's no way that Star
Wars is gonna be this big we could talk
about fan OHS all day to Josh Brolin is
amazing as Thanos he was amazing after
infinity war I think he said the biggest
surprise for him in this all is that
Thanos wound up being a little
sympathetic now you probably don't
sympathize with him completely because
he did erase half of all life in the
universe
whereas infinity war was Thanos his film
he was driving the plot in that and the
Avengers were trying to stop him the
film was really about what he was trying
to do Avengers endgame really does flip
that formula it's about what the
Avengers are doing
coming together and then Thanos trying
to stop them he said that he wanted to
come back as Thanos during the Eternals
franchise because a lot of those films
are gonna be set during the past in the
MCU so we'll talk more about that kind
of stuff the future of the characters in
the next week after everyone has a
chance to see the movie we'll be doing
videos and talking about specific parts
of this movie all the way to the summer
when Spiderman far from home comes out
in July just in general the film was a
great love letter to the characters just
within the context of what was happening
during the film as well as a love letter
to the fans so what'll happen is as
starting Thursday Friday Saturday I'll
start posting my full review Easter eggs
and I'll talk about the end of the movie
there was no post credit scene at the
screening that I went to but they could
just be doing that to avoid spoilers so
just to be safe I would recommend that
you stay through the credits in case
they add something at the last minute
but we'll start talking about that later
this week as everyone starts to see the
movie so be sure to go see the movie as
soon as you can whatever it takes
see this movie whatever it takes I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post a
new Marvel video obviously there's big
Game of Thrones stuff happening this
weekend so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see all
the videos no worries click here for my
brand new Thor video and click here for
my brand new Game of Thrones season 8
episode 3 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]